[Musik]
es spart das ist mit abstand das größte
einberufen es ist mit abstand das geld
sowie die was hier gesehen habe und
jetzt bekommen beim ein video aber ich
hoffe euch gibt gut ich habe mich für
euch mal folgendes vorgenommen und zwar
versuche ich den anfang dieses videos
unter 20 sekunden zu schaffen also halt
der teil wo ich euch versuche zu
erklären worum es geht ja unter 20
sekunden auf jeden fall bin ich erst mal
aufgestanden bin auf youtube begangen
und mir wurde vorgeschlagen da geht
halten wir es als das video besteht aus
ganz vielen kleinen videos die alle
videos zeigen wo es darum geht das hätte
niemand geglaubt wäre das nicht
aufgenommen worden
und das war echt witzig also ich habe
davon so ein paar anguckt und ich dachte
er darüber kann zum video machen
deswegen geht es heute um videos die ihr
niemals glauben würde wäre das nicht
wirklich aufgenommen worden ich denke
mal das war schon überzeugt ist und ich
weiß es nicht es ist kein versuch nicht
zu lachen sondern irgendwie meisten hier
spannt so es passiert nicht immer was
lustiges passiert einfach es ist einfach
übel scalzo also ich weiß nich hat uns
voll unterhalten
ja deswegen auch dieses video in denen
auch erfolge haben wollte das noch
ungleich wird sagen bei 12.000 gleich
machen wir das und jetzt fangen wir echt
und das sogar wenn irgendwelche omas so
trends der jugend darstellen
[Musik]
das ist wirklich noch nie
ich habe mir auch schon viele versuche
nicht zu lachen angeschaut es ist
einfach so viel geiler
[Musik]
das jemand erklären ihm ein schwein
kennt wollten erstmal will meyer denken
in avatar
[Musik]
auch auftaucht aus was man konnte alles
was wenn man irgendwas gesagt hat muss
man danach auf diese ganze draufdrücken
das aufgenommen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
was mich stört ist ganz normal
das gibt's ja echt nur dass sich
menschen halt angezogen oder mehr
angezogen fühlen von irgendwelchen
gegenständen als von anderen menschen
leistet euch also das ist wirklich eine
sache die kann ich nicht verstehen
die werde ich auch nicht verstehen das
geht absolut mich in meinem kopf frei zu
bekommen so blöd sein
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
[Musik]
warum warum das ist doch echt so glaubt
doch einfach mal mit abstand was mit 15
sekunden das ist mit abstand sehen will
kommt klar als solche behandelt fischer
ich danke dir ist es passiert irgendwas
richtig kasse aber das war jetzt also
wenn das kein fake adern frettchen
bilden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
ich kann nicht mehr ich hoffe es hat
euch gefallen die können auch ordentlich
mitlachen lass nach oben genommen also
hier gibt es noch ein video
die sind halt seit gestern online und
sie gehen in amerika über spiral oder
hat generell auf der ganzen welt ich
muss jetzt was essen weil ich mache
gerade eine woche mcdonald s kommt am
sonntag online als video auf keinen fall
verpassen 60 und instagram ab morgen
wieder fahren wird nur 23